la sortie du nouvel album de miossec
auteur compositeur interprète il est
également connu pour ses collaborations
avec hallyday ou bashung son portrait
christophe airaud didier da
rencontre avec un chanteur de 40 ans
et si on parle d'âge c'est parce que
c'est lui qui lui 1964 date de naissance
et titres de son nouvel album je m'en
vais bien
je m'en vais bien avant de te trahir
pourtant miossec n'est rentré en
chansons qu'il ya une dizaine d'années
une voix teintée d et fruits de tabac et
des comptoirs de bistrot des chansons
brutale des histoires de séparation et
de brûlures amoureuse
miossec aime à se dire jean fonniers se
loue la souriante dérision pour définir
son métier et que l'on puisse la chanson
c'est dur parce que ça vire vite la
parodie fin déjà coûté son auteur d'une
caricature ambulante un chanteur ça
s'est fini toujours ont deux trois mois
pas plus
c'est terrifiant christophe ne sait qu'a
écrit pour dire qu'une bâche ou johnny
hallyday est un jour aussi pour juliette
gréco
et les pompes peuvent dire un peu trop
pays
je veux que tu te sentes heureux les
moonves sec tonnes dans la voix de greco
propos d'admiratrices sans réserve à me
promener comme un vieux prêtre annonçant
soir mais bon c'est comme ça que sais je
j'aime comme com comment on peut même un
enfant mais je le respecte comme je
respecte l écrivain et vous quand vous
entendez votre texte interprété
on al impression d de mythomane on fait
donc la paix
sous des airs timides miossec chuchote
les petits drames de l'existence et sous
des allures rock and roll c'est quarante
ans de vie qu'il cache une vie un peu
bancal un peu déchiré
puis avant de refermer ce journal